tous les indicateurs économiques sont au
rouge depuis l'arrivée au pouvoir des
talibans plus d'un enfant sur deux est
sans emploi est pour beaucoup la seule
perspective possible consiste à
s'expatrier pour trouver un travail un
avenir
c'est par exemple le cas de ce jeune
homme revenu au pays voir les siens il
est désormais coincé à kaboul dominé à
6010 alliée à la beauté masquer
ma famille est là et moi je travaille à
moscou quand je suis arrivé tout allait
bien et puis la situation s'est dégradée
on a fermé l'aéroport je n'ai pas pu
partir d'ici la nuit nous avons mal au
coeur en pensant à notre vie qui est si
difficile
c'est comme ça
les autorités elles disent faire le
maximum pour assurer une continuité
économique en commençant par exemple par
verser les salaires des fonctionnaires
nous faisons de notre mieux avec ce que
nous avons nous avons payé un mois de
salaire à nos fonctionnaires qui
travaillent dans divers départements et
ministère
notre cabinet et le ministère des
finances ont annoncé qu'il verserait 3
mois de salaire que l'administration
précédente devait à ses fonctionnaires
nous allons donc leur payer cela
j'espère donc que tout ceci contribuera
à améliorer la situation économique
pourtant il faudra encore du temps pour
remettre l'économie en route avec une
banque centrale paralysé aux premières
loges les commerçants qui se plaignent
du manque de transactions de l'absence
d'activité
al batha
bien sûr nous espérons que la situation
économique s'améliore inchallah si dieu
le veut nous l'espérons ici tout est lié
à la sécurité si la sécurité est assurée
inchallah la situation économique
s'améliorera
maintenant ça va mieux qu'avant les gens
viennent et tout va bien quand le
business reviendra tout ira encore mieux
mais tout va bien pour l'instant soul ou
du cac
dans business / dollar man le pouvoir en
place se défend en déclarant avoir
hérité d'un pays à l'économie en
lambeaux et subir désormais le poids des
sanctions économiques internationales
d'où les difficultés actuelles
ves mais ces sanctions sont très
préjudiciables à notre peuple les gens
n'ont pas accès à de l'argent liquide
les banques ne peuvent pas fonctionner
même les organisations humanitaires qui
veulent aider les afghans ne peuvent pas
apporter d'argent ils ne peuvent pas
retirer de l'argent ne peuvent pas
rémunérer leurs personnels à manille
canada cela exacerbe et aggrave la
situation humanitaire en afghanistan
l'afghanistan semble aujourd'hui frappée
d'une double peine entre une catastrophe
humanitaire et son isolement politique
sur la scène mondiale malgré les efforts
affichés la tâche paraît considérable et
il faudra encore du temps au nouveau
gouvernement pour affirmer sa légitimité